on a tous merci de nous retrouver sur
public sénat depuis hier la commission
des affaires sociales du sénat organise
une série d'auditions afin de préparer
l'examen en séance publique du projet de
loi sur la sécurisation de l'emploi
ce texte sera débattu par les sénateurs
à partir du 17 avril
hier les sénateurs ont donc entendu des
représentants de la cfdt de la cftc ou
encore de la cgc
les trois syndicats qui ont signé cet
accord alors sans plus tarder direction
la salle médicis poursuivre ses
auditions bonne après midi à tous alors
mes chers collègues pour la bonne
organisation de nos débats nous allons
tout d'abord écouter les organisations
syndicales de salariés signataire de
l'accord puis demain nous aurons les
organisations syndicales non signataires
et ensuite nous aurons les organisations
patronales
j'ai donc eu le plaisir pardon
d'accueillir aujourd'hui pour la cfdt
messieurs patrick pierron secrétaire
national et monsieur christian janin
secrétaire confédéral pour la cftc
monsieur thouvenel vice-président et
pour la cgc madame marie françoise
leflon secrétaire national accompagné de
monsieur franck boissard experts
techniques
je vous propose donc mes chers collègues
de donner la parole à chacune des
organisations syndicales pour nous
présenter
andris en guise d'introduction pour nous
présenter leurs principales observations
sur cet accord du 11 janvier et sur sa
déclinaison dans le texte législatif tel
qu'il est en discussion au parlement
ensuite je donnerai la parole aux
rapporteurs pour une première série de
questions et bien évidemment ensuite
l'ensemble des sénatrices et sénateurs
pourront à leur tour s'il le souhaite
demander des explications
supplémentaires aux organisations
syndicales si cela vous convient
je commence par ordre alphabétique donc
par la cfdt
monsieur pierrot ou monsieur janin si
vous voulez bien où nous comme vous
voulez ou madame le flambeau à l'envié
alors par ma gauche très bien pour la
cgc madame leflon ensuite la et ensuite
je terminerai par ma droite alors oui
mesdames et messieurs c'est une actrice
dessinateur je suis ravi de vous
présenter l'alizé en acf cjc sur cet
accord c'est accords que nous avons
signés et auquel nous tenons parce que
nous considérons que c'est une prise de
responsabilités et un acte de
modernisation du marché du travail dans
un constat économique d'une situation
extrêmement difficile avec un taux de
chômage qui s'accroît dans une pente
très régulière depuis 17 mois qui
atteint des niveaux très difficilement
supportable pour ensemble la société
c'est aussi une situation qui touche les
jeunes qui ont encore des taux de
chômage de 22 %
et puis toutes les conditions inhérentes
à aux indemnisations qui s'épuise la
durée des droits qui est s'allongent les
situations de précarité qui augmente et
surtout l'impossibilité pour les
salariés ou pour les demandeurs d'emploi
d'avoir une vraie vision professionnelle
donc nous avons abordé cette négociation
dans un vrai souhait de trouver des
solutions avec les partenaires qui nous
entoure est que ce soit nos collègues
d'organisations de salariés mais que ce
soit aussi les collègues des
organisations patronales puisque cet
accord pour nous et finalement avec
beaucoup de doigté un juste équilibre
entre les attentes des entreprises dont
nous avons considéré qu'elles sont
importantes en ce moment pour sauver la
compétitivité des entreprises et par
conséquent les emplois qui nous attend à
nous partenaires sociaux et la cfe cgc
très attaché à sauvegarder les droits de
ses salariés dans les périodes d'emploi
mais aussi de rupture de manière à avoir
un parcours professionnel moins
douloureux et moins haché c'est donc
pour ces raisons que la cfe cgc
considère que cet accord se architecte
est architecturé autour de quatre points
principaux à la fois c'est un projet qui
créerait 50 est des droits nouveaux qui
ont été effectivement nécessaire face
aux contrepartie de libéralisation si ce
n'est de flexibilité nécessaire au
marché des entreprises donc qu'il
s'agisse de la complémentaire santé je
pense que le débat amènera certainement
des points plus précis mais en tout cas
pour nous aussi bien l'amélioration la
porte de la portabilité et la création
et l'extension de cette couverture est
extrêmement importante
la lutte contre la pauvreté la
prolifération des cdd puisque le constat
pour nous est que au fil des années le
cdm ne restent pas ce qu'ils devraient
être est c'est à dire sa nature
systématique dans bouche puisque une
entreprise devrait investir sur un
profil particulier sur des compétences
et non pas sur une nature de contrat
même si on sait très bien qu'il ya les
facteurs de chiffre d'affaires et de
marché baisse de compétitivité qui joue
n'en demeure pas moins que ce souhait de
revenir un fondamental comme celui-là
passer forcément par une taxation des
contrats courts sans que cette taxation
ne soit excessive puisqu'il ne s'agit
pas de freiner l'embauchent dans
notamment pour les petites et moyennes
entreprises
alors effectivement cette surcotisation
il n'était pas question non plus de la
faire peser pour nous sur le déficit à
l'heure actuelle très lourde de l'unedic
et que donc il fallait envisager
sur cotisations qu'ils soient finançable
c'est pour ça que le les chiffres et les
durées des contrats choisi nous semble
un équilibre subtil un droit qui est
important pour nous aussi parce qu'il
doit être à mon avis développer
redévelopper redimensionner
surdimensionné c'est la création du
compte personnel de formation
c'est pour nous un des facteurs clés qui
devraient tout au long de la vie
s'adapter tant en entreprise corps de
l'entreprise et donc c'est pour nous le
premier pas de modernisation de la
formation professionnelle avec un f
majuscule un autre droit auquel la cfe
cgc est attaché par ce que l'on
considère qu effectivement dans nos
populations de l'encadrement c'est un
droit ok sur lequel nous avons beaucoup
travaillé qui devraient être
opérationnels et aller vers plus
employabilité s'agit du droit à une
période de mobilité volontaire sécurisé
alors effectivement il n'est pas qu'un
seul qu'un simple concept qui peut
répondre à une réalité c'est pour ça que
nous avons fait pas mal de propositions
qui sont dans l'accord de manière le
sécuriser au maximum et à lui donner une
vraie image de visibilité enfin le
recours à temps partiel qui est pour
nous important puisque c'est les
premiers fondements d'un vrai travail
contre la précarité
bien entendu le détail portera débat si
les branches ne savent pas s'en emparait
suffisamment mais l'ensemble de ces
points sont des points forts pour nous
dans cette partie que je considère être
une partie de création de droits alors
cet accord et sa transcription puisque
la cfe cgc considère que la
transcription a été tout à fait au plus
près de notre volonté de négociateurs
c'est c'est donc un accord et son projet
de loi qui a un deuxième axe très
important puisqu'il renforce la
formation des salariés tant sur les
perspectives que sur les choix
stratégiques de l'entreprise
alors le fait le plus important le plus
novateur qui était déjà dans les germes
du dialogue social est incontestablement
la base de données cette base de données
qui sera à disposition des élus et qui
pour nous doit être accessible à tous
les représentants du personnel c'est à
dire pas seulement laissé eux mais aussi
des dp chsct les représentants syndicaux
alors je pense qu'on sera amené
effectivement dans le débat en parler la
tenue de cette base de données le suivi
de cette base de données devra toujours
un autre sens faire part à chaque fois
d'une information salariés dès lors
qu'elles auraient été modifiés ça peut
être les comptes ça peut être le bilan
social tout ce qui est donné qu'ils sont
amenés avec modifié devront être donné
lieu à l'information
alors l'entreprise pourra le faire à sa
manière mais il faut pas considérer
cette base de données comme quelque
chose de statique mais bel et bien la
faire vivre et en prévenir les salariés
dès qu'elle a été modifiée
voilà alors on a un autre point de
satisfaction aussi danser ces
informations anticipé désir paix et ce
qui était un point très important pour
la cfe cgc sont les règles de
gouvernance dans l'organe de gouvernance
lui-même
c'est vrai que nous avons obtenu là
la présence la généralisation je dirais
plus que la présence puisqu'elle
existait déjà mais sa généralisation de
présence d'administrateurs salariés avec
voix délibérative c'était un point
extrêmement fort pour la cfe cgc
parce qu'il nous semble que tout
dialogue social doit commencer par un
échange entre un chef d'entreprise et
ses salariés donc dès lors qu'il y avait
des instances de gouvernance il faut
qu'il y ait échange sur les stratégies
de l'entreprise c'est vrai que le seuil
de 10 milles sur les groupes
internationaux de 5000 et c'est vrai que
le nombre peut-être et est un peu léger
en tout cas par rapport à ce qui se
pratique dans certaines entreprises
mais en tout cas ils avaient davantage
de s'adosser sur les préconisations du
rapport gallo a minima et puis il est
surtout sa généralisation un point fort
a donné dans l'image du dialogue social
c'est pour ça que c'est un point
important pour nous de même que la
négociation de l'ajpae c est un facteur
très important on connaît le concept de
la cgpc on le connaît mais il ne nous
semble pas suffisamment opérationnel
l'approchent par lequel on donne des
pénalités une entreprise qui pratique ne
pratique pas une négociation 10 pc ou
qui ne fait que des plans d'action peu
contraignant et était pas la meilleure
approche est en tout cas elle ne peut
jamais être coupée sur les marchés de
l'emploi sur la territorialité avec une
gps et territoriales et avec la partie
des sous traitants qui est aussi une clé
du marché de l'emploi à l'heure actuelle
donc le renforcement de cette gpc y
compris du plant des orientations du
plan de formation
on n'a pas encore atteint les
négociations du plan lui-même mais en
tout cas c'est un premier pas est très
important et c'est d'ailleurs pour ça
qu'elle va permettre dans ce cadre-là de
négocier les mobilités internes dans
l'entreprise
donc la preuve du dialogue social via
les administrateurs via la base de
données et ensuite avec ses possibilités
de travailler via la gpe eux c'est donc
permettre d'approcher la suite de
l'accord du 11 janvier vers des données
plus conjoncturelle c'est à dire que
tout ce qu'on a vu en amont pour nous
peut être considérée comme une approche
structurelle un dialogue social qui se
forme qui va se développer
et puis les difficultés de structures
elles sont là et donc les anticipations
nous allons les retrouver dans les
différentes phases de l'accord c'est
pour ça que pour nous l'anticipation et
la négociation d'un accord sur la
mobilité interne
dès lors bien entendu king ne comporte
pas une réduction d'effectifs et
j'attire votre attention sur cette
partie là lorsqu'une entreprise on veut
restructurer son outil de travail
je pense que la mobilité interne est
indispensable mais pour cela il faut
qu'elles soient négociés par un accord
en amont et pour cela elle implique
qu'il n'y ait pas de réductions
d'effectifs par ailleurs de manière à ce
qu'il n'y ait pas de confusion des
genres et que les élus soient bien
concentrés sur les contreparties à
donner aux salariés de manière à ce
qu'ils aient accepte qu'il puisse faire
valider cette mobilité par rapport à
leur équilibre entre eux la vie privée
et la vie professionnelle c'était la
mention qui nous semblait être la règle
de base pour approcher et accepter pour
le salarié une mobilité interne
la cfe cgc a toujours prôné pour le
salarié qui d'ailleurs ne pouvait pas
assumer cette mobilité interne le fait
qu'il puisse s'en aller avec un
licenciement et que nommé plutôt qu'un
simple licenciement donc l'amélioration
du texte en ce sens nous convient aussi
essayez vous vous ennuyez pour la suite
alors d'y évoquer cette première
approche conjoncturelle de l'entreprise
par une mobilité et puis ensuite
effectivement on peut imaginer ça a été
imaginé dans l'accord que l'entreprise
ait davantage de difficulté et qu'elle
soit amenée à travailler sur le chômage
partiel auquel cas cfe cgc appelle de
ses voeux à une simplification rapide
des deux systèmes que son chômage à
l'heure actuelle et l'apl des deux
manières avant un seul outil à la
disposition des entreprises qui est une
simplicité et une visibilité et une
indemnisation pour le salarié lié à des
plans de formations ponctuelles qui soit
tout à fait opérationnel et rapidement
le peu d'utilisation d'heure du chômage
partiel à l'heure actuelle prouve qu'il
ya nécessité de changer ce système là et
puis dans une phase ce puits
supplémentaires ou suivante si le
chômage partiel avait été suffisant et
que les difficultés de l'entreprise sont
trop importantes nous nous trouvons
effectivement avec des accords de
maintien de l'emploi qui là encore
seront négociées en amont et c'est pour
nous le point fort de cet accord avec un
accord majoritaire et c'est la
négociation de cet accord devra bien
entendu être largement encadré c'est la
raison pour laquelle dans cet accord
nous avons demandé à maintes reprises
qui est à la fois des retour à bonne
fortune
ensuite pour les salariés qui est
également un parallélisme des formes ou
un parallélisme financière de la part
des dirigeants des actionnaires et des
salariés et que cet accord était négocié
à plus de 50% de façon à ce que
l'ensemble des contreparties soient
négociés en faveur
salariés c'est un article extrêmement
important qu'il nous semble être le
point d'équilibré de la rencontre des
salariés qui vont accepter des activités
baisse de rémunération pour essayer de
sauver l'entreprise et je pense que il
faut noter ce progrès de l'accord voilà
pour les grandes règles s'est passé bien
évidemment dans une quatrième partie de
l'accord par ce cet accord qui va
moderniser le contentieux prud'homal
puisque à la fois vers la phase finale
de difficultés de l'entreprise
c'est-à-dire le pse qui sera ou négocier
ou soumis à homologation est à la fois
sur les raccourcissement des délais
temps de la prescription que des
montants proposés de la négociation
toutes ces parties la finale de l'accord
qui était difficile à accepter
au premier abord le son en contrepartie
des sécurité qui ont été données et donc
ce que la cfe cgc espère c'est qu'au
fond dans cet accord dans toutes ses
phases elle y aura gagné la force du du
dialogue social un jeu un petit peu
exprimé ce cas c'est fo cgc a essayé de
construire du début à la fin et pourquoi
il tient cet accord et à une
transposition au plus près de ce qu'elle
a exposés
merci madame leflon je vais donner la
parole à la cfdt je ne sais pas le sujet
n'a monsieur piron
voilà bonjour messieurs mesdames les
sénateurs et sénatrices et je vous
remercie de l'invitation pour cette
audition qui est importante pour nous
puisque c'est un lieu d'échangés qu'on a
peu l'occasion d'effectuer entre les
partenaires sociaux et les élus de la
nation et en ce sens quoique c'était
important après négociation qu'on puisse
échanger sur la bonne compréhension de
ce qu'on a voulu faire lors de cette
négociation notamment donc la série t je
vais passer plus vite peut-être puisque
avec marie-françoise heureusement on a
des points communs puisqu'elle a signé
le même texte et donc il ya des choses
qu'elle a mis en avant qui sont dans le
texte sur lesquels je vais passer plus
rapidement ce que j'aurais donné c'est
l'état d'esprit de la cgt quand on est
entré en négociation sco souhaité c'est
d'avoir un accord interprofessionnel
dans un contexte difficile
difficile de crise ou économique on
voulait un accord qui change un peu la
donne qui change la donne pour les
salariés qui change la donne pour les
entreprises et qui permettent de
démontrer que les partenaires sociaux
étaient en capacité de de s'engager de
prendre leurs responsabilités et de
promouvoir l'emploi ou tenter promouvoir
l'emploi et tenter de faire reculer la
précarité dans une période de chômage
importante qui progressaient donc on y
rentrer en voulant obtenir des nouveaux
droits pour les salariés
on voulait pas un accord qui était un
accord un peu d'effets enfin un accord
qui aurait été défensif uniquement et
donc on s'est fixé comme objectif
d'avoir des nouveaux droits de sécuriser
les parcours professionnels puisque ça
nous paraissait essentiel à un moment où
on fait pas tout son parcours dans la
même entreprise c'est être sécurisée
entre deux emplois de donner des
garanties au niveau des salariés quand
ils perdaient leur emploi et que perdre
leur emploi c'est pas perdre leurs
droits
donc ça posait la question du
rattachement des droits et c'est pour ça
que dans cet accord il ya des droits
rattachés à la personne et plus
uniquement aux contrats de travail et à
l'entreprise ce qui fait qu'on les garde
y compris en période de chômage
de d'avoir des mesures de pour faire
reculer la précarité et je le dirai tout
à l'heure je pense qu'un des éléments
importants c'est l'encadrement du temps
partiel subi qui touche essentiellement
les femmes et les cellules
monoparentales on a essayé dans le cadre
est au mieux me semble-t-il
et puis dans le même temps c'était
d'affirmer la place du dialogue social
la place de la négociation comme un des
éléments centrale pour créer aussi de la
norme sociale et que ça permette de
prendre en compte les réalités des
salariés et des entreprises qu'on
replace les salariés au centre des
préoccupations et des décisions et donc
ça ça passe par les accords majorité à
mais j'y reviendrai ça passe par la vie
en force et des institutions
représentatives du personnel
c'est eux c'est européen où ce dp chsct
en amont des décisions et notamment sur
l'utilisation des aides publiques par
exemple
voilà donc les mieux représentés enfin
mieux représentés ou associer les
salariés ou leurs représentants plutôt
dans les organes de 10 de délibération
avec voix délibérative les organes de
décision avec voix délibérative ça
c'était important
voilà dans le quel état d'esprit en été
et en même temps on a cherché à avoir un
accord qui influe influencent les
comportements des entreprises et des
employeurs
mais quand je dis entreprise c patronat
et syndicats
et quand j employeurs ses employeurs là
par contre c'est important pour nous
puisque on faisait le constat qu'une
entreprise avant cet accord et avant
cette loi nous l'espérons une entreprise
qui favorise l emploi sur le long terme
est une entreprise qui favorise par son
action il recours aux cdd ou contrats
courts qui favorisa précarité chômage
être été pareil dans ce pays demain ça
sera plus le cas une entreprise qui fait
de la transparence
une entreprise qui négocient une
entreprise qui associe ses salariés elle
est traitée pareil que si elle ne fait
pas aujourd'hui demain ça sera plus qu'à
est une entreprise qui forme ses
salariés une entreprise qui forment pas
ses salariés elle est considérée pareil
aujourd'hui demain ça sera plus
k et donc c'était un accord qui devait
jouer c'est comme ça qu'on le voit
l'avenir nous le dira puisque c'est ce
qu'on a essayé de faire c'est un accord
qui dit clairement
voilà le comportement vertueux que l'on
souhaite pour les entreprises c'est la
négociation c'est l'application des
salariés c'est la transparence et de
l'anticipation et cdd nouveaux droits
et contrairement mais je vais vous
démontrer j'ai essayé contrairement à ce
qui été dit par certaines organisations
non signataires que je commenterai pas
ce que je respecte chaque position pour
nous si les parlementaires transpose
l'accord dans la loi les nouveaux droits
seront actées tout de suite dans le code
du travail par la loi et la flexibilité
demander où la flexibilité possible sera
acté que si la négociation d'accords et
soumis à l'approbation d'un salarié sur
deux part le représentant un passé des
accords majoritaires à 50%
donc c'est les nouveaux droits tout de
suite et c'est la flexibilité si il y à
négociation c'est pas l'inversé ça c'est
important de se le dire
donc moi pour moi il ya cinq ans il ya
dix nouveaux droits dans l'accord 1
il ya dix nouveaux droits dits droits
qui n'existe pas aujourd'hui alors je
vais pas vous les listes et mais j'ai
zéro on peut vous les aimez il y en a
cinq qui sont emblématiques me
semble-t-il mais il ya dix ans tout dans
l'es5 emblématique c'est ce que marie
françoise a dit c'est bien sûr la
génération de la complémentaire santé
qui touche quatre mille quatre cent
mille salariés qui n'en n'ont pas du
tout et donc ils vont accéder une
complémentaire santé et
et je ne sais plus 4 millions de
salariés qui cela paye elle-même
eux-mêmes et qu'ils vont la voir sous un
contrat collectif payer à 50% par
l'employeur et donc sans ça ça change
une couverture de complémentaire santé
qui est bon pour les séries mais qui est
bon pour les entreprises d'avoir la
possibilité de se soigner
me semble-t-il les droits rechargeables
qui sécurise entre le deux emplois la
période de chômage mais qui incite au
retour à l'emploi aussi puisqu'on n'a
pas peur de reprendre un emploi plus
court que le précédent puisqu'on perd
pas les droits acquis par le précédent
et sans sac les droits rechargeables
il sécurise la période entre deux
emplois et il incite un retour à
l'emploi même si c'est un emploi de plus
courte durée que ce qui avait été fait
avant ce qui n'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui mieux encadrer et mieux
rémunéré le temps partiel ce que je
disais qui est une source de précarité
énorme dans plusieurs secteurs mieux
rémunérés dès la première erreur à 10%
alors qu'aujourd'hui c'est zéro la
majoration
demain ce sera 10 % dès la première
heure complémentaire au delà du contrat
et mieux encadrer alors nice est un
casse-tête temps passé c'est un vrai
casse tête entre ceux qui sont dans le
commerce et services ceux qui sont dans
la propreté
ceux qui sont en service à la personne
voyez bien que c'est des situations
différentes
donc on a prévu quand même un repère
base horaire de 24 heures par semaine
comme un repère avec possibilité
dérogation par accord de branche en
fonction des réalités des réalités du
secteur concerné donc ça c'est important
par contre on a essayé d'éviter
l'éclatement horaires des salariés qu'on
retrouve alors c'est vrai souvent dans
la distribution la propreté souvent
faibles des salariés du salariat féminin
qu'on retrouve avec quelques heures le
matin quelques heures en fin de matinée
entre midi et deux quelques heures le
soir qui fait que ces personnes sont
mobilisées 8 à 10 heures sur leur lieu
de travail ne travaille que 4 à 5 heures
et non pas la possibilité de retrouver à
deuxième employeur c'est en cela qu'on a
essayé de répondre par l'organisation
par demi-journée et journée pour que
quand l'entreprise ne peut pas leur
offrir des oeuvres groupe
quel regrouper et sur des la semaine
entière qu'elle ait au moins la
possibilité d'avoir des heures regroupés
par demi-journée pour qu'elle puisse
retrouver un deuxième employeur et
pouvoir vivre dignement de leur travail
ce qui est pas le cas dans bon nombre
des cas aujourd'hui
et puis après il ya le bien sur le
compte personnel de formation qui doit
permettre se former de la sortie de
l'école jusqu'à la retraite qui n'est
pas lié au contrat de travail en
entreprise parce que on voit bien qu'en
2008 on avait négocié le dif
transférable et qui se transfère pas
donc il fallait mutualiser plus
fortement cette formation pour que la
formation soit rattachée à la personne
n'est pas l'entreprise et au contrat de
travail commencé une source d'inégalité
dans salariat et que ça une fois qu'on a
créé cette enveloppe qu'on estime comme
un nouveau droit qui va être tout de
suite dans la loire il va falloir le
remplir avec une gouvernance à
financement et autres mais ça c'est la
deuxième étape de négociations et de la
loi qui doit arriver bientôt mais il ya
une concertation en cours
donc on voulait pas chanter non plus la
concertation en cours entre partenaires
sociaux
et ça demandera une concertation est à
région mais le véhicule est là
n'existait pas avant
donc ça c'est important voilà sur après
la taxation des contrats courts
honnêtement qui va être les droits
rechargeables puisqu'on sécurisent
l'entrée et la sortie de l'emploi c'est
un signe qu'on a voulu donner fortement
entre partenaires sociaux ont dix ans
patronat et syndicats - ceux qui signent
disent clairement que les contrats
courts de moins de 3 mois de moins d'un
mois au moins d'une semaine qui sont qui
ont augmenté d'à 86% par exemple en 2011
ne peuvent pas être la durée de l'emploi
et l'entrée dans l'emploi normale dans
ce pays et qu'il faut retrouver une
forme d'emploi long après il faut voir
la nature des contrats mais qu' on peut
pas construire une vie de famille se
loger quand on sait pas si le mois
d'après en à son contrat qui va perdurer
voilà donc c'est un signe fort c'est pas
économique les 0,5 1,5 et 3 % c'est pas
ça qui va charger changer la donne
on s'est dans le même temps qu'on a
besoin de contrats courts en fonction
des réalités ou de l'aspect cyclique des
activités donc l'objectif c'était de
dire les partenaires sociaux 10
entreprises
attention il ya un dérapage vers
l'utilisation abusive des contrats
courts
donc il faut revenir à des comprenons
donc ça c'était c'est important c'est
important de le prendre comme ça et pas
de le prendre comme une mesure
économique
une sanction on vit des employeurs voilà
mais c'est donner un signe deuxième
pavés qui me paraît important c'est la
place du dialogue social au delà pour
les nouveaux droits j'en ai cité 5
il y en a 10 vous pouvez regarder il y
en a dix ans l'accord ce qui est
important après en terme de dialogue
social et qui permet d'asseoir la
négociation et le dialogue social et
l'association des salariés avant en
amont des décisions c'est la possibilité
d'avoir une base de données qui élargit
les informations prévues aujourd'hui par
le code du travail
aujourd'hui la base de données enfin
journal code du travail que les
informations qui sont prévues demain la
base de données va reprendre l'ensemble
des informations qui sont aujourd'hui
prévues par le code du travail mais
ville va les allergies re à des domaines
comme des éléments stratégiques ou
d'investissement de l'entreprise tous à
3 en 1
donc on est sur une vision à trois ans
qu'on a pas aujourd'hui de l'année en
cours jusqu'à l'année jusqu'à ou trois
ans plus tard va donner des éléments sur
bacon bien d'être public chaque
entreprise touche combien de crédit
d'impôt des 20 milliards par exemple
mais d'autres aussi touche et qu'elle
leur utilisation donc des éléments comme
ça qui sont importants le nombre de
contrats fin des éléments qui sont
importants et sur lesquels les
partenaires sociaux n'ont aucune
information
aujourd'hui dans l'entreprise on va les
avoir avec cette base de données
ce qui va permettre de prendre en compte
les impacts sociaux des décisions
éventuelles ou de mesurer avant que ça
arrive les difficultés prévisibles à 3
ans et y compris de discuter des choix
stratégiques d'investissement de
recherche dans l'entreprise qui
aujourd'hui est essentiellement du
malade du ressort du management et pour
se faire aider
il ya une expertise nouvelle qui a été
créée une expertise nouvelle qui permet
de décrypter de deux participent au
diagnostic dans le ceo ou autre
organisation patronale et syndicale dans
l'entreprise et de décrypter les
éléments économiques qui aura et compris
d'accompagner les élus sur si la base de
données elle évolué que les élus
puissent s'appuyer sur une expertise
nouvelle donc c'est aussi un nouveau
droit mais plus sur le dialogue social
que pourrait servir directement avoir
des représentants des salles avec voix
délibérative ans sont arrêtés là parce
que ça touche que du trail que du
commerce
on a estimé qu'on n'avait pas la
légitimité d'aller plus loin et que ça
c'était le débat parlementaire qui
devait affiner cette question c'était en
dehors de nos prérogatives
voilà une négociation tous les trois ans
sur la politique sociale sur les
parcours professionnels
ça c'est un élément important qu'il faut
associer à la base de données puisque la
base de données va donner des
informations qu'on n'avait pas et qui
doit donner et nous notre souci c'est
donner de la visibilité à trois ans au
moins aux salariés quant à leur emploi
évolution de métier évolutions
technologiques mobilité utilisation des
contrats et que ça ça va se négocier
avec l'orientation du plan de formation
là je peux c'est l'utilisation des
contrats chaque fois qu'on embauche on
peut on peut discuter pourquoi s'est dit
pourquoi un temps partiel pourquoi à cdd
pourquoi l'intérim
aujourd'hui c'est jamais discuté les
contrats de génération qui sont repris
dans cette négociation tous les trois
ans et la mobilité potentiel possible
technologique ou géographique qui sera
négocié et tout ça se donnera lieu à un
accord tous les trois ans et ça c'est
important
on a obtenu un meilleur encadrement des
accords de maintien dans l'emploi
notamment sur le fait je n'aurais deux
exemples d'encadrement sur le fait qu'on
peut pas baisser les salaires par
exemple en dessous d'un
deux fois le smic parce que là on estime
qu après c'est plus possible de gagner
sa vie correctement mais aussi que quand
ça va mieux que le cadre difficile est
passée et ben qui en retour à meilleure
fortune
c'est à dire que ceux qui ont fait
l'effort puisse avoir les fruits de
leurs efforts voilà et y compris que si
au bout de deux ans ça marche pas en
retour dans la procédure actuelle et
dans la procédure actuelle bien sûr tout
ce qui a des mythes et autres et sont
calculées sur le contrat existant
d'avant la dérogation ainsi à une baisse
de salaire par exemple possible de
négocier d'homologuer plans sociaux je
passe vite mais ça c'est important aussi
toutes ces flexibilité possible c'est
sûr accords majoritaires à 50%
voilà j'ai envie de dire pour finir que
pour nous influencer comportement des
entreprises en faveur de l'emploi donné
des signes dans ce niveau-là avoir des
nouveaux droits en période de crise
alors qu'il ya des pays aujourd'hui le
marché du travail égal moins 30 % de
salaire etc etc
en europe c'est important pouvoir
anticiper les mutations et pour rassurer
les salariés aux décisions c'était
important gagner en transparence et en
visibilité
c'était important aussi et envie de dire
c'est que pour nous c'est plus qu'un
accord équilibré entre de l'éventuelle
flexibilité et de et des droits des
salariés
c'est un accord qui au service de
l'emploi des entreprises et des salariés
pour relever le défi de la performance
et de sa compétitivité
monsieur pierron je passe la parole à
monsieur thouvenel compléter ce tour de
table et ensuite on passera aux
questions merci présidente
mesdames messieurs je vais éviter de
répéter ce qu'on ex éléments dits mes
camarades signataires un élément de
contexte
j'entends beaucoup de choses sur cet
accord et beaucoup de choses totalement
faux ou inexacts et donc pour apprécier
cet accord il faut l'apprécier en lisant
les articles et les annexes
point barre puisque par exemple j'ai
relevé la déclaration de vos anciens
collègues tonitruant qui publiquement
nous dit cet accord un contenu qui va
aggraver d'une manière considérable les
conditions d'existence des travailleurs
dans les grandes entreprises puisque
dorénavant n'importe quel grand patron
peut changer la durée du travail
hebdomadaire et la paye sans que les
travailleurs en particulier puisse s'y
opposer même si ça modifie leur contrat
de travail
je me suis dit qu as tu fait puis comme
j'ai un peu une petite connaissance du
fait social je suis mais changer la
durée du temps de travail ou la
rémunération des salariés
est ce qu'aujourd'hui hier
unilatéralement les employeurs ne
pouvait pas le faire
est ce que les gens de chez bosch il ya
trois ans l'on fantasmait est ce que les
gens de chez conti l'on fantasme est
attelé roi est ce que ceux qui en 2004
déjà ou une mesure de baisse de
rémunération unilatérale de l'employeur
l'on fantasmait non qu'est ce que change
l'accord c'est que par rapport à une
situation
il a même déjà un élément considérable
plus de décision unilatérale de
l'employeur accord signé par les
organisations syndicales à 50%
renforcement du droit syndical et du
pouvoir syndical encadrement de la
procédure on vous l'a dit notamment
quand vous regardez la nex si l'accord
n'est pas respecté comme ça a été le cas
continental clairoix clause pénale
clauses pénales sanctionnant
l'entreprise
alors certains ont visiblement mal lu on
vise une lamballe compris il faut
s'attacher ce cas dans ce texte et ce
texte très très très globalement est
favorable salariés est là il est pas
favorable que salarié les favorable aux
salariés les favorable aux entreprises
il est favorable à notre pays en fait
ceux pour lequel il est moins favorable
c'est sans doute les actionnaires mais
peut-être que les actionnaires aient
pris trop de pouvoir ces dernières
années et qu'il fallait un peu remettre
les choses en place
d'où d'ailleurs l'arrivée des
représentants des salariés dans les
conseils d'administration et les
conseils de surveillance même si c'est
uniquement pour les entreprises de plus
de 5
il s'est pas suffisant mais demain
j'espère que ce sera trois mille 2000
on n'ira pas dans les plus petites ça
aurait pas de sens mais on a enclenché
la mécanique et cet accord c'est à la
fois ce qui là est ce qui vous a été
décrit les nouveaux droits mais c'est
aussi une mécanique qui s'est mis en
place et qu'il faut faire vivre
d'ailleurs on voit que dans l'accord sur
certains points on va continuer à
approfondir dans négociations et c'est
surtout une mécanique qui apporte la
coresponsabilité entre les employeurs et
les salariés
et ça c'est essentiel c'est une
association entre la force de travail et
la force de la direction et la force du
capital au lieu de toujours se regarder
en chiens de faïence et se renvoyer les
choses à la figure moi je note que quand
on a commencé à négocier il y avait
trois millions de chômeurs quand on a
terminé il y en avait plus de cent mille
mais si on fait rien on continue comme
ça ça ne va faire que croître et
embellir et ça c'est désastreux
et si vous prenez tout l'accord eh bien
ce sont des points positifs à quelques
rares exceptions près qui pour la
plupart ont été vidés de leur contenu
j'attire votre attention sur une
interprétation mauvaise par exemple sur
ce qui est les prud'hommes
au départ le patronat voulait que toute
condamnation prud'homale ya un barème
obligatoire et on passe par là c'est
terminé
en finale il y à un barème indicatif
uniquement pour la conciliation
prud'homale et il est bien indicatif
dans l'accord puisque l'accord dit les
parties peuvent
et si le projet de loi était très bien
rédigé il ya quelques petites erreurs
qu'il faut corriger et par exemple le
projet de loi à tendance visiblement à
considérer que ce barème est obligatoire
il n'est pas obligatoire il est
indicatif le pauvre il est sorti de ce
stylo donc je le connais bien et peuvent
en français ça veut dire ils peuvent
concilier sur ce qui indiquait ou non
ils peuvent concilier sur ce montant ou
en dessous ou au dessus
ils font comme ils veulent et ce il
concilie pas on continue la procédure
prud'homale comme avant et donc vous
voyez qu'un certain nombre d'articles
qui sont restés
parce que ces négociations parce qu'on
peut pas faire perdre la face aux
partenaires quels qu'ils soient
et donc quand ils ont des engagements en
dix ans n'oublions jamais que cette
négociation s'est fait avec une pré
campagne électorale au medef une pré
campagne électorale à la cgt fait que
les positions des uns et des autres
étaient peut-être influencé par ces
congrès qu'elle est venir
le medef s'est avait besoin de voir un
article ou pour les prud'hommes
on mettait quand même un bar et man est
long il est indicatif et voilà comment
il faut lire l'accord donc le lire
réellement voir ce qui est mis dans
l'accord
est ce que nous nous demandons au
législateur
c'est de respecter ce qui est venue de
cette maison d'ailleurs qui était de
dire que quand il ya un problème qui
touche les partenaires sociaux passait
prioritairement aux partenaires sociaux
dans les deux saisies s'il arrive à être
d'accord et bien le législateur
considéra que les corps intermédiaires
c'est bien c'est ce qu'on n'a pas
connues sous d'autres gouvernements vous
disais que les corps intermédiaires vous
pouvez chanter jouer du pipeau aller
manifester dans les rues à porter des
dossiers gros comme ça
de toute façon moi je sais tout je
décide de tout et je vous écoute pas là
les choses changent
on lui dit partenaires sociaux si vous
prenez vos responsabilités
on va en tenir compte on va regarder on
va préciser parce que cet accord n'a pas
été écrit non plus par des juristes
comme vous l'êtes par des législateurs
et donc il ya des points qu'il faut
préciser éclairé ça c'est normal mais il
faut surtout pas le dénaturer
parce que ce serait un très très mauvais
signe qu'ils bloqueraient les choses
pour les futurs accords et ce serait
dire aux partenaires sociaux vont ne
servait à rien je crois que les
partenaires sociaux ont quand même une
utilité dans ce pays en tout cas celle
ici par ces trois organisations de
représenter majoritairement les salariés
maintenant les chiffres sont
incontestables et donc qu une majorité
de représentants des salariés qui avec
une majorité de représentants des
employeurs se mettre d'accord sur
quelque chose je pense que c'est un
signe important qui mérite d'être
respecté
monsieur thouvenel je vais laisser la
parole tout de suite aux rapporteurs
pour une première série de questions
merci madame la présidente madame
messieurs j'ai quelques scrupules à
revenir sur les questions que j'avais
préparé d'abord parce qu'il me semble
que pour une très large part dans votre
présentation vous y avez répondu
néanmoins je me permettrai d'insister
sur un ou deux points
néanmoins avant je voudrais souligner
que ce tour de table et devant mes
collègues a été très intéressant il faut
remercier la présidente de la commission
des affaires sociales d'un avoir pris
l'initiative car il a permis de mettre
en évidence premier point que vous vous
retrouviez pour l'essentiel sur la
traduction du projet de loi tel qu'il
avait été élaboré
deuxièmement très clairement et vous
l'avez indiqué chacun en insistant
plutôt sur telle ou telle volée vous
avez souligné que cet accord et ce
projet de loi qui en résultaient ils
étaient porteurs de droits nouveaux pour
les salariés en particulier vous avez
tout d'abord insisté sur le fait que ce
texte ils étaient porteurs de droits
nouveaux
à la fois de nature individuels mais
aussi collectifs pour les salariés en
insistant sur quelques aspects que je
voudrais juste rappeler l'accès à la
complémentaire santé la création du
compte personnel de formation et et
d'autres éléments comme le droit à la
mobilité sécurisée bref je ne vais pas
reprendre l'intégralité de vos propos
deuxième élément que je voudrais
souligner pour vérifier que
effectivement il fait consensus entre
vous c'est que il porte
avez vous dit un progrès dans la lutte
contre la précarité dans l'emploi et
dans l'accès à l'emploi
un exemple les droits rechargeables à
l'assurance chômage mais aussi ce qu'a
indiqué la cfdt
la hausse des cotisations pour les
contrats courts en indiquant que c'était
un signe
mais qui avait vocation précise
le mans a privilégié les cdi troisième
élément que je voudrais souligner qu'il
a aussi vous rassemble c'est
l'anticipation négocier des mutations
économiques que permet cet accord
notamment je pense en particulier à
l'importance qu'il redonne à la gps et
cela a été dit la refonte du dispositif
de chômage partiel et et surtout c'est
me semble-t-il dément pivot de cet
accord la création des accords de
maintien dans l'emploi et enfin le
dernier point vous avez rappelé que et
vous étiez réunis sur ce point que cet
accord encadraient les licenciements
économiques avec une modification des
procédures mois je souhaiterais qu'on y
revienne néanmoins pour clarifier le
débat avec une modification profonde des
procédures des procédures applicables
aux casseurs aux plans de sauvegarde
dans l'emploi pour bien nous assurer
ensemble que nous sommes là sur des
éléments de progrès c'est c'est la
raison pour laquelle néanmoins je
reviendrai sur quelques-unes de mes
questions considère globalement que sur
la question une que je vous ai préparé
le rôle confié aux délégués syndicaux de
l'entreprise et osier rhdp vous y avez
les uns et des autres répondu et en
moins je sais que c'est une des
questions qui préoccupent beaucoup de
mes collègues et il n'ya pas
d'inconvénient à y revenir
il me semble aussi que et c'est la cfdt
qui a insisté sur ce point les mesures
visant à limiter les cdd courts
vous avez rappelé que c'était un premier
pas un signe qui était donné et vous
nous direz si à votre point de vue à ce
stade on peut en dire davantage
troisième question ses surgelés vocal
instant parce que
ces centrales et on entend souvent cette
question les futurs accords de maintien
dans l'emploi vous paraît style
protecteurs pour les salariés
vous y avez répondu au titre de la cftc
mais véritablement ce qu'on entend aussi
c'est que finalement il rien de bien
nouveau et que c'est plutôt inscrire
dans le code du travail un élément de
régressions pour les salariés je crois
qu'il faut qu'on aille au bout de ce
point là pour nous assurer en effet que
nous sommes sur un élément de progrès ce
que pour ma part je crois la cinquième
question c'est là elle est un peu plus
technique
vous l'avez vous l'avez évoqué monsieur
thouvenel c'est sur la question du
contentieux prud'homal je pense que là
dessus
effectivement vous avez rappelé que le
barème n'était qu'indicatif mais
l'ambition de ce texte me semble-t-il
et j'aurais qu'on insiste sur le sens
l'ambition de ce texte cessé de
développer la conciliation le recours à
la conciliation
pensez vous vraiment que ces
dispositions permettront un recours
effectif à la conciliation et j'aimerais
bien alors aussi vous l'avez pas trop
évoquer au sauf par par allusions sur la
question des délais de prescription
parce que c'est une question qui revient
souvent comme un élément de régression
en le droit des salariés et enfin
dernier point on m'excusant d'avoir été
peut-être un peu long dernier point
avait voulu connaissance des amendements
qui ont été adoptés par la commission
des affaires sociales de l'assemblée
nationale qui quittent au demeurant qui
au demeurant sont en nombre et à mon
point de vue de portée limitée
est-ce que vous avez un élément
d'appréciation sur ces amendements
nous serions très très très curieux de
vous entendre là dessus
si c'est possible eh bien je recommence
dans le même ordre peut-être si vous
voulez répondre à l'amour flou où
monsieur boissard l'appréciation sur le
rôle confié aux délégués syndicaux dans
entreprises cotées pour pour nous on
souhaite qu'elles soient élargies le
plus largement possible
ce qui veut dire que à chaque partie de
l'accord dans laquelle on est concerné
que ce soit sur la consultation de la
base de données que ce soit aussi et
beaucoup sur la phase de consultation
unique du chsct qui est prévu un moment
donné de l'accord on souhaite notamment
sur suel chsct qu'il intègre tous les
chsct locaux parce que dans les cas de
restructuration il est hors de question
de laisser sur la route une
problématique d'un endroit d'un lieu
d'un site qui n'était pas vu en amont
dans la consultation alors il y a des
délais préfixe fixée pour ces
consultations il faut être vigilant il
ya une hiérarchie en fonction du nombre
de salariés de ces projets il faut être
vigilant pour que ça tienne bien dans ce
cadre voilà c'est à dire deux mois trois
mois
pour nous c'est essentiellement ces
points là qui sont importants c'est
d'ailleurs ne pas oublier voire
peut-être intégrer les rs éventuellement
sur la question 2 sur la question 2
écoutez moi je vais reprendre ce que ce
qu'a dit patrick en tout cas auquel on
était tous les trois sur la même
longueur d'onde dans les négociations
parce que effectivement un accord comme
celui là ne passe pas sans un échange
entre les uns et les autres pour
confronter nos points de vue c'est c'est
une manière d'enclencher un regard et
d'essayer de stopper cette hémorragie de
création de cdd on ne peut pas continuer
à créer comme sur les embauches 90 % des
embauches sont faites sur des contrats
courts alors un contrat court quand on
réfléchit à la pertinence de son motif
tu parles pas d excès de d'activité mais
il est utilisé à toutes les sauces
alors peut-être qu'il ya des dérives
parce que le salarié lui-même préfère
avoir sa prime de précarité celui qui
est assez mobile professionnellement
mais tous les salariés ne sont pas
mobiles professionnellement c'est pas
vrai donc accompagné sur des contrats
plus longs en créant des périodes de des
simulations des périodes intégration
dans les entreprises ce serait plus
intelligent donc c'est un premier pas
balladur et vous mettez derrière cdd
courts et cdd plus longs
ecoutez-la l'accord il parle et il ne
taxe que les contraintes d'un mois et de
trois mois ça nous semble bien parce
qu'à six mois que déjà est une
expérience professionnelle correcte
voilà si tu es cdu la notion d'emploi
durable
oui mais ça n'est pas l'intérim c'est
uniquement cdd et et même la hiérarchie
sur les cdd d'usagé le taux est plus bas
parce qu'il ya des grandes pratique de
branches professionnelles dont il faut
respecter les pratiques de branches
parce que dans cet accord on en parle
au premier niveau interprofessionnel
mais sur beaucoup de sujets comme le
temps partiel il est reporté aux
branches parce que seules les branches
maîtrise le lait il ya une étude
d'impact pour savoir combien ça va
représenter de salariés en cdd l'intérim
par exemple est ce qu'il ya une étude
d'impact pour nous dire on lira en
lisant les ans les ententes est moi je
les ai plus là mais en les en-têtes est
en tout cas devenue tout est en tout cas
en coup je pense que ça fait une rentrée
de 750 millions à 1 milliard dans les
caisses de l'unedic et en nombre c'est
extrêmement difficile parce que la cause
du mal à suivre
parce qu'il faut extraire les cdd de
remplacement pour congé maternité et cdd
de aux activités donc les mais les
motifs pertinents sont très difficiles à
suivre un prêt techniquement par par
l'unedic et en os x et c'est l'effet
comportemental sur lequel on a plus joué
et puis on a de toute façon prévu de
faire des points réguliers de suivi de
cet accord les partenaires sociaux dont
on pourra toujours un flux échangés au
modifié alors le contenu des futurs
accords de maintien de l'emploi pour
nous oui
pour la cfe cgc il est protecteur il est
protecteur pourquoi joseph l'a dit
l'histoire ne nous a pas attendu les
accords dit compétitivité il existait et
existe toujours dans un cas on prend sur
les pintes salariale dans un autre on
prend sur les comptes et un de temps
dans le dernier chez michelin c'est
s'aider jours de rattrapage
donc ce toute façon ça existait sauf que
c'était sans normativité et dans des
situations où les salariés sont
forcément incité à accepter les
propositions de l'employeur parce qu'ils
ont peur de perdre leur emploi et donc
les sécurités que l'on a mise et quand
même été renforcé par par la
transcription puis puisque on a renforcé
le fait de pouvoir faire du chômage
partiel en même temps que les accordent
de maintien de l'emploi le taux minimum
qui a été évoquée de 1,2 smic
les mesures pénales si ça c'est pas
respecté de tout ça ce sont des
garanties quand même importante de 2 et
c'est aussi pour ça que sur la mention
nous la cfe cgc de l'accord majorité
avaient été écrits au moins 50% en on
avait suggéré que soient plus tôt écrit
plus de 50% pour être bien sûr que ce
soit n'a qu'un accord majorquin un
accord majoritaire dans une entreprise
c'est pas neutre ça veut dire qu'il ya
énormément de discussions entre les
partenaires sociaux de d'obédiences
différentes et donc il ya il ya quand
même des non signataires de l'accord
interprofessionnel qui signent des
accords consignes à un accord la semaine
dernière chez renault et qu'ils n'ont
pas signé l'accord interprofessionnel ce
qui veut dire que la réalité de
l'entreprise est quand même très
important
puis ce retour clause de bonne fortune
il est quand même avec un facteur très
important
les propositions initiales désaccord et
de nombreux accords qui ont été signés
avant reposer en cas de refus du salarié
sur un refus sui generis
si le salarié ne pouvait pas pour des
raisons financières au personnel assumer
ce changement temporaire que nous avons
fixés sur deux ans d'ailleurs de contrat
il était licencié à l'heure actuelle il
est licencié pour motif économique
c'est quand même pas nous ce qui veut
dire qu'on peut travailler sur toutes
les garanties a donné l'assaut
le csp de toutes ces choses et puis au
final si jamais l'accord de
compétitivité n'a pas marché s'il doit
être indemnisée l'assurance chômage
il l'est sur ses droits et ses
ressources antérieur tout ça pour nous
sont des protections assez importante
voilà sur les questions rapidement 4 et
4 les pse elle contenu des pse pour nous
s'il est vu par accord collectif
il sera bien pensé bien adapté et puis
les mesures d'accompagnement seront
renforcés pour nous en amont afin qu'ils
soient validées lors de la consultation
et sinon l'homologation est bien pour
l'acfci si on est très attaché à ce que
cette homologation il porte sur le
contenu des mesures qui sont mises par
rapport aux moyens de l'entreprise aussi
je pense qu'il faut jamais perdre de vue
certaines situations difficiles de pse
et puis d'autres situations où les
entreprises ont d'autres moyens quand on
regarde le bilan voilà
et puis l'heure le contentieux le
dernier point sur les discussions sur le
contentieux prud'homal alors joseph l'a
exprimé beaucoup mieux que moi
d'une manière plus théâtral mais c'est
tout à fait vrai c'est cette année
c'était le seul moyen que nous les
partenaires sociaux salariés nous avions
de contrepartie face au projet initial
du medef et je pense qu'il faut quand
même s'y référer puisque le titre 5 du
premier projet du medef était
extrêmement libératoire voire
insupportable puisque il voulait faire
prévaloir le fond sur la forme il
voulait créer des blocs de compétences
il voulait changer le motif de l'ordre
des licenciements
on a obtenu quand même que le critère
des compétences ne devienne pas le seul
et unique critère en cas licenciés
qu'est-ce que quand même pas neutre on a
obtenu que la transaction avec le
montant des pénalités ne soit 4 titre
indicatif
donc ce sont quand même eu un
adoucissement de ce texte est enfin sur
les délais de prescription que vous avez
posé et qui était aussi un point très
difficile pour la cfe cgc de réduire ce
délai de cinq ans on avait une première
proposition qui était de 1 an
c'était compliqué d'imaginer qu'en un an
il fallait se décider très vite d'autant
plus que pour l'encadrement et sont
souvent des cadres forfait on ne
retrouve les heures supplémentaires ou
les heures excessive qu'en faisant des
calculs et c'était assez loin simplement
quand il a fallu trouver à mi chemin
parce qu'une négociation s'il trouvait
le mi chemin entre les deux nous on a
regardé les statistiques et 80 90 % des
des procédures sont entamées dans les
deux premières années
donc on a suggéré de séparer les motifs
et de trouver une d'une durée de deux 2
qui est de 2 en finale sur les motifs de
rupture de contrat et en a obtenu trois
ans sur ce qui le concerne les salaires
et les accessoires voilà mais c'est le
fruit d'une négociation et ça faisait
une contrepartie des droits sur lequel
on a négocié voilà pour la cfe cgc le
rapporteur veut rajouter une petite
question oui juste une petite
observation parmi les réflexions que
vous venez de présenter sauf erreur de
ma part je voudrais vous informer en
faire profiter l'ensemble de l'assemblée
que lorsque vous souhaitez un
élargissement de la base de données aux
délégués du personnel lorsque aussi vous
souhaitez que en particulier les ch
c'était locaux soient plus impliqués
dans le dispositif de concertation
je crois que mon collègue à l'assemblée
a présenté deux amendements ils se
sentent en avoir connaissance
j'ai bien voilà très bien merci
on continue le tour de table
et puis après si on veut que nos
collègues mes collègues puissent poser
un peu des questions
j'ai essayé de faire plus court et de
répondre brièvement que ce qu'on n'y a
pas retiré pondu et je veux pas redire
je pense que l'enjeu à travers cet
accord de replacer le dialogue social au
coeur comme un élément central de plume
de la confiance qui peut y avoir entre
et sérieuse employeurs quant à l'avenir
qu'ils ont à dessiner ensemble c'est ça
un peu long je sais c'est que eh bien
tout ce qui est à venir visibilité
flexibilité négociations de normes
sociales et bien ça doit se faire par la
négociation et par l'accord majoritaire
alors là ça va plus loin que la loi
parce que l'accord majoritaire dans tout
ce qui est flexibilité va à 50% la loi
sur la représentativité prévoit qu'un
accord majoritaire et mazouté à partir
de 30 % de plus longtemps et s'arrête
donc là on a voulu en plus bien sécurisé
le fait que ben pour tout ce qui est
perçu et plan sauvegarde de l'emploi si
on veut alléger des procédures août
il faut un accord à 50% si on veut un
accord de maintien dans l'emploi
il faut un accord de 50% je tiens à
préciser aussi dans ce cadre là qui est
l'enjeu de placer le dialogue social au
coeur et de recréer de la confiance
entre entre les employeurs et les
salariés
c'est dans le maintien dans l'emploi qui
posait là est ce que les engagements
pris favorise la sécurité des salariés
j'ai envie de dire les a déjà l'accord
il est prévu pour deux ans maximum
il doit être prévu que si c'est un
problème conjoncturel c'est à dire qu'il
ya possibilité de recourir une nouvelle
expertise pour vérifier le diagnostic
c'est essentiel si diagnostic est pas
partagé y aura pas d'accord de toute
façon donc la question du diagnostic
et de la base qui ouvre la négociation
donc la base de deux ce qui fait qu'on
est d'accord sur le constat est
essentiel et ses deux ans maximum et
qu'en plus ces salariés est sollicité
deux fois pour donner son avis il est ce
site est une fois sur le projet d'accord
et donc qui donne lieu à un accord
majoritaire ou insérés sur deux plus
d'installer sur deux doit dire oui pour
qu'il se mette en oeuvre et après les
solliciter si les concernés par la
dérogation à son contrat de travail où
il peut dire oui et non 1 sur le la
possibilité de les solliciter deux fois
ça c'est important de le dire comme
c'est important de dire aussi qu'en fin
de compte les accords de maintien de
l'emploi
c'est un outil de plus dans la boîte à
outils re je sais que c'est pas le bon
terme en ce moment mais mais pour les
entreprises pour les entreprises pour
les entreprises c'est à dire que ça je
n'ai pas ouvrir c'est à dire que ça ça
vient et ça se conjugue avec les autres
dispositifs
ça se conjugue avec les autres
dispositifs donc ça se conjugue avec le
chômage partiel mais ça répond pas aux
mêmes choses et donc à nouveau le
diagnostic est important un accord de
maintien dans l'emploi
il vise à passer un cap difficile sans
viser une baisse d'activité au contraire
il faut relancer l'activité parce que on
veut relancer les parts de marché c'est
le cas de des bateaux l'anneau nord
brittany ferries est là il faut relancer
donc il ya un accord de maintien dans
l'emploi et alors que le chômage partiel
c'est une baisse d'activité qu'il faut
gérer
donc on voit bien que l'idée que l'on a
à travers cet accord et ils trouvèrent
la simplification du chômage partiel
c'est de dire eh ben voilà
patrons et syndicats d'une entreprise
vous avez une difficulté en vous mais un
outil en place mais en l'encadrant pour
que comme l'a dit joseph donc je
reviendrai pas dessus que le salarié est
ici là des garanties par poser fort qui
fait il s'assure que les garanties
soient respectés à ce titre c'est vrai
que des accords on a fait la liste nous
globalement il y en a déjà bon nombre d
accord est signé par toutes les
organisations syndicales pas en même
temps un il ya des accords signés mais
toutes les orientations syndicales ont
déjà signé des accords de maintien dans
l'emploi
seule différence qu'il y a maintenant
avec notre encadrement c'est qu'on peut
aller en justice si c'est pas respectés
alors qu'avant c'était pas le cas et on
était souvent le bec dans l'eau
donc c'est une question de pratique
syndicale mais de pratique managériale
de transparence de diagnostic de
confiance et d'engagement et de
responsabilité et c'est ça que c'est
vers ça qu'on vous l'aller sur cet
accord sur la taxation des contrats
courts je vous ai pas répondu madame
c'est la prise parce que on a eu un
doute on a en gros en 2011
on a 19 millions de cdd qui ont été
passées dans ce pays
19 millions énorme sur ces 17 9 millions
10,9 millions il y en a 17 de moins de
trois mois
c'est pour ça qu'on dit la règle c'est
l'embauché qu'il fallait faire quelque
chose
c'est la base qui nous a servi à
négocier et là où j'ai un doute c'est à
discussion que j'avais parce que moi
j'ai j'avais le fait qu'il ya ya or
c'est hors contrat de remplacement et on
n'a pas les statistiques aujourd'hui ni
avec le commencer la structure qui donne
les statistiques la dares par exemple
sur lesquels on s'est appuyé on n'a pas
les statistiques sur les cdd d'ordre de
remplacement mais qui sont inévitables
et les cdd dans bauges d'une semaine
d'un mois et moins de trois mois alors
on sait que ça explose globalement mais
on n'a pas le détail après par
sous-rubriques en a demandé justement à
la hâte de voir si par la suite on
pouvait pas fine et cela c'est pour ça
je peux pas répondre sur rue mais le
volume ses 19 millions 10,7 millions de
wons 3 mois voilà donc ça montre quand
même l'ampleur dès contrats courts dans
ce pays et c'est pour ça qu'il fallait
une mesure plus que sam plus que
symbolique pour dire ça peut pas être la
règle
ça peut pas être la règle avec autant de
de chômeurs dans ce pays
ce que j'ai pas on n'a pas souligné mais
qui est important c'est qu'à côté de la
taxation des contrats courts
on favorise le cdi pour les jeunes de
moins de 26 ans qu'un élément important
dans la discussion et qui a été un des
éléments qui donnent aussi un signe et
on dit aux employeurs si vous voulez pas
avoir cette taxation ou avoir des
exonérations un social en plus ou qui et
neutralise cette taxation et bien
transformer les cdd pour les jeunes de
moins de 26 ans cdi et là c'est une
opération neutre et nous ça va dans le
sens de l'emploi tout ce qui en a voulu
faire c'est l'autre sens l'emploi
l'intérim est sorti on a eu un débat
là-dessus et on s'est dit qu'en fin de
compte une boîte d'intérim c'est une
boîte oui un employeur qui utilisent des
gens et qui leur proposait contrat
intérim donc on les a considérés comme
une entreprise à part entière et on n'a
pas considéré l'entreprise qui est
demandeur du serbe demandeuses du
service dans les taxation des contrats
courts parce que on pense que toute
façon intérim est nécessaire c'est pas
la question c'est le fait qu' il faut
sécuriser les séries qui sont en intérim
y compris entre deux contrats parce
qu'entre deux contrats ils ont pas le
droit
mais ils sont le bec dans l'eau et donc
l'idée et ça a commencé
c'est de négocier le parcours des
intérimaires essaient de négocier le cdi
intérimaires et c'est de négocier les
périodes y compris de formation entre
deux contrats qui leur assure une
rémunération 1
c'est ça l'idée et c'est pour ça qu'on a
considéré dans l'accord
l'intérim est les patrons de l'intérim
comme des patrons d'une entreprise comme
une autre et donc à ce titre là on les a
sortis bien sur la taxation des contrats
courts utilisatrices des contrats courts
c'est ce qu'on ait said et donc on a une
revoyure
oui dans six mois et si l'accord ou la
négociation n'aboutit pas à un accord
dans cette branche atterri je rappelle
que ça fait dix ans qu'ils essaient
d'ouvrir cette négociation qu'il n'y
arrivait pas dans la branche interview
qui est dans la fédération des services
pour nous un commerce et services grâce
à l'accord interprofessionnel
il faut espérer maintenant que et c'est
leur intérêt de tous
il faut espérer qu'ils améliorent les
parcours professionnels la sécurisation
des parcours professionnels des
intérimaires
je regarde mais je crois que c'est en
complément
en complément de ce qui a été dit alors
les amendements l'assemblée nationale ou
de la commission des affaires sociales
on est très content parce que ça va dans
le bon sens on a eu et on souhaite à la
voir aussi avec vous on a une bonne
articulation et avec le rapporteur de la
loi et avec le gouvernement et les
députés
on a fait tous les groupes
parlementaires où on a expliqué notre
démarche comme on l'a fait de on le fait
devant vous on a vu tout le les groupes
parlementaires en amont de l'ouverture
de la commission des affaires sociales
on a eu des rapports
régulier avec le rapporteur de la loi on
a eu des rapports bien sûr avec cabinet
le ministre sapin sur la compréhension
des articles parce que c'est pas évident
de traduire un accord équilibré allemand
à un projet de loi avec une écriture
juridique et on a vu toute la complexité
et qui à bon nombre de zones d'ombré
juridique a complété dans l'accord et je
trouve que on en est à une phase où on
en train de démontrer et votre travail
le complétera que la démocratie sociale
ou au moins dialogue social peut se
conjuguer avec la démocratie politique
et que ça peut se faire sans autocensure
mais dans une complémentarité bien pensé
pour favoriser l'emploi et les parcours
des salariés
voilà je thouvenel pour compléter après
merci je vais je vais pas reprendre je
vais donc le premier point je crois que
dp la première question sur le
rapporteur s'était répandu cdd juste
ajouter une chose la mécanique les
l'externe accord qui devait vivre la
mécanique qu'on a mis en place ces de
renchérir les contrats qui sont des
contrats de précarité qui sont pas de
précarité j'allais dire de bon sens on
cherche pas renchérir le cdd qui est de
remplacement d'un congé maternité
d'absence pour maladie
on cherche pas enchérir et c'est pas
dans le texte
les cdd pour les vendanges on cherche à
mettre en place une mécanique qui
renchérit le coût de l'abus de la
précarité et dans le même temps ça a été
dit on abaisse les charges notamment
pour l' embauche des jeunes de moins de
26 ans directement on s'est dit alors
certains disent ben oui mais ce que vous
faites payer en plus à l'entreprise là
vous leur faites un cadeau de l'autre
côté
personnellement je m'en moque
complètement mon but dans la vie c'est
pas de renchérir le coût du travail
mon but là c'est de faire que notamment
pour les jeunes
il est un accès dans le marché du
travail directs en cdi parce que s'ils
veulent un logement s'ils veulent vivre
correctement si s'ils vont voir leurs
banquiers mieux vaut avoir un celi qu'un
cdd
c'est cette mécanique là qu'on met en
place alors peut-être que c'est pas
parfait
mais moi je n'ai pas la prétention
d'arrivée tout de suite à la perfection
mais j'essaye détendre sur le problème
qui a été posée est-ce qu'on va pas
inscrire dans le code du travail un
élément de régression notamment pour les
accords de matière d'emploi c'est une
vraie question
mais si on inscrivait rien dans le code
du travail mais ça serait le bonheur des
ultra libéraux c'est tout ce qu'ils
souhaitent surtout ne touchez pas
n'inscrivez rien laissez nous faire on
fait on fait depuis des années on va
continuer à faire si on inscrit quelque
chose si on met des règles et des normes
si on encadre comme ça a été dit ont
sécurisé pour les salariés
bien sûr nous c'est tout ce que nous
souhaitons évidemment ça sera dans des
cas difficiles parce que on se retrousse
les manches et on dit au moins trois
organisations ici présentes on prend nos
responsabilités
et oui c'est dans les cas où ça va mal
c'est dans les cas où l'emploi est en
cause c'est dans les cas où l'entreprise
peuvent fermer et on dit avec un accord
de ce type pouvoir aux organisations
syndicales de signer ou pas je suis un
peu étonné que certaines organisations
légèrement plus importante que la mienne
et si peu confiance leurs délégués
syndicaux qui veulent pas donner le
pouvoir d'avoir une meilleure
information et de prendre leurs
responsabilités pour sauver leurs
emplois
et si c'est fait pendant la durée de
l'accord pas de licenciement pour cause
économique et le pari qu'on fait c'est
que les choses se redresseront si ça
marche comme chez paule klein
hydraulique et ben tant mieux parce
qu'aujourd'hui salariés de potelets
hydraulique
ils sont très contents d'avoir fait des
efforts pendant quelques mois parce
qu'ils ont toujours leur boulot et gagne
plus qu'avant et si ça ne marche pas les
salariés n'ont rien perdu puisque tout
est calculé comme si rien n'avait été en
baisse et au contraire si ça marche
ils ont un retour à meilleure fortune
qui les fait participer la bonne marche
de l'entreprise
alors peut-être qu'on aurait pu mieux
faire eh bien il est regrettable que
ceux qui ont la possibilité corps eu la
possibilité d'améliorer les choses
nous en venons pas apporté leur baguette
magique pour le mettre dans le texte
donc ce texte est bien meilleur que
l'état actuel et c'est comme ça qu'il
faut voir tout l'accord point par point
est ce que par rapport à la situation
actuelle quand ce texte en application
ce sera mieux ce sera moins bien sur ce
point là à mon sens c'est indéniable
pour les ps c'est pareil
inscrire dans un texte que pour un plan
social
aujourd'hui on consulte et on prend
l'avis du comité d'entreprise etc
demain il y aura toujours cette
consultation est cet avis mais en plus
les organisations syndicales pourront
signer c'est à dire qu'elles pourront
dire oui on nous a apporté tous les
éléments sur les conditions les raisons
économiques qui font qu'un plan social
donc c'est apporter du pouvoir aux
organisations syndicales et si c'est pas
la voie choisie c'est la voix de
l'homologation
c'est à dire qu'on demande à
l'administration de se pencher sur le
problème
j'entends des gens qui depuis des années
peut-être à juste titre nous réclame le
retour de l'autorisation administrative
de licenciement
c'est pas exactement ça mais c'est quand
même un pas vers sa et donc ça sécurise
par rapport à aujourd'hui
sauf si on n'a aucune confiance dans
l'administration et sauf si on n'a
aucune confiance dans les organisations
syndicales
c'est me semble-t-il un autre débat sur
la question que vous avez posé sur le
rapporteur sur la prescription
mais vous avez raison très clairement
c'est une régression c'est une
régression qui était voulue par le
patronat qui à mon sens c'est totalement
stupide parce que quand je dois du
salaire à quelqu'un il est normal de lui
verser
même si les éléments de salaire parce
que la personne qui ne sait pas sa
convention collective sans rencontre
sept ans après ce serait normal de lui
verser
là on descend les délais mais il fallait
bien apporter des contreparties
fusse-t-elle stupide parce que comment
ça se passe dans la réalité
allez je dois dix ans de salaire demain
on va me dire ah ben non vous allez
pouvoir les réclamer pendant trois ans
eh bien je réclame trois ans de salaire
et les sept ans qui m'a qui manquent
je leur est l'avant dommages et intérêts
est généralement le juge les accorde
mais c'est une régression j'en suis
d'accord
voilà maintenant je serais heureux de
répondre si je le puis aux questions qui
pourraient être posées alors j'ai déjà
quelques inscrits je voulais simplement
peut-être
au vu de l'enthousiasmé de nos de nos
personnes auditées rappeler qu en 2005
et un texte qui a été adopté qui inverse
sa hiérarchie des normes skis
aujourd'hui dans le code du travail
n'est pas forcément ce qui est dans les
entreprises puisque un accord
d'entreprise peut être moins bon qu'un
accord de branche donc tout ce que vous
nous avez dit la cie à condition
évidemment que les accords d'entreprise
le reprenne ce qui n'est pas gagné
d'avancé même si monsieur thouvenel
croyez moi je fais confiance aux
organisations syndicales pour défendre
les salariés dans l'entreprise mais
enfin il me semblait que c'est important
de rappeler ce fait là parce que il me
semble pour ma part que non seulement il
ya une hiérarchie des normes qui a été
introduite il ya déjà quelques années
mais qu'avec ce texte on va encore un
peu plus loin dans l'inversion de la
hiérarchie des normes puisque voilà donc
voilà donc je pense qu'il faut quand
même voir sa sous l'eau ne complet du
code du travail et des textes qui
régissent le droit du travail
aujourd'hui
par ailleurs d'autres amis ont déjà été
signés par par le passé certains l'ont
été ont été retranscrits de manière
assez
fidèle d'autres bien moins donc voilà
c'est aussi le travail de législateur
ensuite de donner son avis et son point
de vue sur les textes qu'ils viennent
vous disiez tout à l'heure à quoi
serviraient les organisations syndicales
si on les écoutait pas mais alors à quoi
servir lyon nous si nous ne pouvions pas
faire notre travail de législateur donc
il me semble aussi important quand même
de prendre en considération et le
dialogue social il me semble qu'à la
commission des affaires sociales on
s'évertue de le faire puisque je vous
rappelle tout à l'heure ce règlement qui
fait que nous auditionnons et je le fais
systématiquement on n'a pas eu beaucoup
de textes mais on en a eu quelques-uns
nous nous consultons en tout cas les
organisations syndicales sur toutes les
propositions de loi qui touche au droit
du travail
donc le dialogue social pour moi est
important d'ailleurs si on peut
l'inscrire dans la constitution je n'y
verrais que du positif à condition
toutefois que le dialogue social soit
véritablement représentatif et et qu'il
ne soit pas je veux dire empreint d'une
certaine parfois d'une certaine toute
puissance d'une organisation qui n'est
pas ici aujourd'hui que l'on reverra
demain mais qui parfois m'inquiète un
peu dans le résultat qu'on peut qu'on
peut obtenir moi je suis effectivement
favorable au dialogue social au fait
qu'il soit dans la constitution et au
fait que les unes et les uns nous soyons
entendus de bonnes manières
je voulais rajouter ces quelques petits
mots à monsieur le rapporteur alors il y
à monsieur thwala de madame procas ya
monsieur van weynbergh monsieur le maire
monsieur barbier pour le moment donc ça
fait 1 2 3 4 5 monsieur teulade le
premier oui naturellement mais le
considérons tous que tout ce qui peut
favoriser le dialogue la démocratie
sociale nous devons même si elle n'est
pas parfaite
la regarder dans son programme ouah je
veux simplement une question la
couverture complémentaire
c'est un progrès incontestable la
couverture complémentaire obligatoire
pour tous les salariés
mais est ce que par hasard ont pu être
évoquée lors des discussions la mise en
place de cette couverture complémentaire
par certaines compagnies d'assurance qui
parce que ça va quand même la prise en
charge de 50 % par le patronat ça va
coûter une certaine somme
la prise en charge de cette couverture
complémentaire en introduisant ce qu'on
appelait le bonus malus c'est à dire
certaines compagnies d'assurances
introduisent la couverture
complémentaire et le coût de cette
couverture est fonction du temps de
maladie des salariés autrement dit si
vous êtes malade on augmente la
cotisation de la couverture
complémentaire et si vous n'êtes pas
malade dont la diminue ce qui veut dire
que c'est une remise en cause totale du
principe de solidarité entre les bien
portants et ce qui donc pas la chance de
l'être
première question les deuxième question
cette couverture complémentaire
comment s'étendre à tel moment de la
cessation d'activité je vous propose
qu'on prenne toutes les questions c'est
ensuite donc madame procast mais merci
madame la présidente je vais poursuivre
sur sur la complémentaire maladie
simplement une question est ce qu'il ya
des dispositifs qui vous permette qui
permettront aux entreprises et aux
salariés de se rendre compte si la
nouvelle couverture maladie est moins
intéressante que l'assurance maladie
complémentaire qu'il pouvait avoir
individuellement
pourquoi avoir fait ce choix d'un
accor pourquoi ne pas laisser le choix
aux salariés de dire je garde ma
complémentaire maladie qui me convient
mais mon entreprise me paie une partie à
hauteur de la partie que l'entreprise va
mettre pour couvrir d'autres salariés
ma deuxième question porte sur
transposition de la nied annie davy dans
l'ain peu évoquée moi je voudrais savoir
quelle serait votre attitude si la
transposition que nous allons voter
s'éloigne de d'assez loin de l'accord
que vous avez tous les trois signés les
dernières questions rapides
les chiffres sont impressionnants 17
millions de cdd d'au moins trois mois
pour 19 millions de cd des parents
pourquoi n'avez-vous pas décidé de
supprimer le cdd dans le droit du
travail
merci merci madame la présidente
bon moi je me réjouis de cette belle
unanimité de la part des organisations
syndicales signataires
ça ne m'étonne pas évidemment mais je
m'en réjouis parce que ici même je me
souviens d'une réunion à l'initiative du
président larcher à l'époque qui se
rappelait que le ministre du travail
qu'il avait été avait souhaité amplifier
et élargir développer le dialogue social
eh ben moi je vous dis merci merci
d'avoir répondu par les fai à cette
demande qui émane est aussi de notre
commission sociale ici au sénat alors
j'ai entendu aussi le président hollande
nous dire que ça serait cette loi
l'accord tout l'accord mais rien que
l'accord et que tout amendement qui
seraient proposés par les deux
assemblées devrait être approuvé par les
organisations signataires
première question c'est comment vous
allez faire
comment allons-nous faire plus
exactement puisque nous sommes partis
prenants il va falloir à nouveau
négocier entre vous et puis nous si j'en
crois évidemment la parole j'ai pas de
raison de la mettre en doute la parole
du président
deuxième point je reviendrai pas sur les
différents points qui ont été évoqués et
je pense que avec les auditions que nous
avons eues avec des uns et des autres
j'ai eu beaucoup de réponses
c est mon groupe a eu beaucoup de
réponses sur les points qui le
chagrinait le temps partiel notamment
sur la mobilité interne
on sait qu'il faudrait réécrire je les
ai entendus par les uns et par les
autres
le motif motif économique motifs
personnels il ya une différence avec
l'accord et qui est quand même assez
assez importante mais je n'insisterai
simplement sur les délais préfixe j'ai
entendu le partenaire principal
devaux accord le medef du côté patronal
dire que ça y avait une différence avec
l'accord national sur le délai préfix de
l'article iv et qu' il serait peut-être
nécessaire d'encadrer la prolongation
des délais par le juge qui est prévu
effectivement dans la loi sinon ça
risquait d'être utilisé par ceux qui
n'ont pas signé
voilà la raison qui nous a été avancée
moi je suis pas en mesure d'en juger
mais je vous pose la question est ce que
ça vous paraît nécessaire de changer
effectivement cette rédaction de la loi
voilà merci merci monsieur le maire
merci mais moi je ré insiste la sueur
déjà deux interventions me connecte la
des pros cassia pour que vous ne
puissiez bien nous nous manière très
synthétique mais quand même complète
nous nous d'écrire à nouveau comment ça
va se passer pour cette couverture
complémentaire de santé obligatoire de
tout le monde de se félicite alors est
ce que cette couverture est ce qu'il va
y avoir des appels d'autres des appels
d'offres est ce que ça va être au niveau
des branches est ce qu'on est au niveau
des entreprises est ce que ça va
concerner des appels en direction des
organismes de prévoyance ou des sociétés
mutuelles mutualistes ou alors des
compagnies d'assurances multiples donc
là je pense qu il faut que les choses
soient très claires donc ça c'est un
premier point dans ce cadre là compte
tenu du volume important deuxième fois
et là ça a été effectivement abordé
aussi mais j'aimerais que être très
éclairé dessus lors de la cessation du
d'activité de d'un employé pour un
chauffage par exemple est ce qu'il y est
elles sont les dispositions est-ce qu'il
va repartir dans une complémentaire
individuel pris lui même ou est ce que
il ya un système
réfléchis qui pourrait être de l'ordre
de 2 non pas de là d'un droit
rechargeables pour la couverture chômage
mais de quelque chose qui serait un peu
dense est dans cette optique comment ça
va se passer d'une manière pratique
parce que c'est quand même important et
l'emploi n'est pas avide ans adore
entreprise peut y avoir des périodes de
chômage commence à peu tout ceci être
articulé je suis intéressé là dessus par
ailleurs quatre millions de personnes
qui vont quitter les une couverture
individuelle prise complémentaire
individuel c'est quand même une masse
importante et certaines mutuelles je
pense notamment à la fédération
nationale des mutuelles indépendante qui
s'inquiètent en disant bon voilà il va
se passer des choses
on risque d'avoir des dégâts collatéraux
si on peut dire et puisque hiver un
reformatage et on risque d'avoir même
des licenciements dans ce cadre-là par
pertes et ouled de notre de notre
activité d'une partie notre activité
puisque c'est personne d'une manière
considérable risque et ça se comprend
d'aller vers une couverture
complémentaire si sûr d'autres
organismes alors moi j'aimerais que vous
puissiez bien reformater tout ça qui
c'est une avancée tout le monde le
perçoit bien on s'en félicite mais il
faut lorsqu'on a des contacts avec nous
à la base dans nos permanences avec des
personnes qui s'intéressent et notamment
des salariés qui s'intéressent à ces
questions et ô combien s intéresse eh
bien on voudrait pourra aussi apporter
des réponses lors relativement précises
merci monsieur barbier
merci madame la présidente est
simplement pour ce qui avait été dit que
on est interpellé quand même cet après
midi par une réflexion générale sur ce
projet notamment par rapport entre le
texte que vous avez signé et le projet
de loi qui est présenté par le
gouvernement
est ce que pour vous celui ci correspond
est-ce que vous souhaitez notamment bien
entendu on a détaillé chacun des droits
etc
mais on l'a évoqué ce problème un peu
philosophique et qui passe un petit peu
à la trappe
le préambule du titre 2 concernant la
négociation enfin l'état d'esprit entre
les partenaires sociaux dans le texte
que vous savez signé est-ce que sur
cette affaire avait considéré que le
projet de loi tel qu'il est elle
satisfaisant et le deuxième point que je
veux évoquer c'est de savoir dans le
cadre de responsabilité des
organisations syndicales
comment vous voyez les perspectives de
stratégie de l'entreprise à trois ans
comment envisagez-vous d'intervenir de
pouvoir intervenir d'une manière
suffisante sur sur cette stratégie et
moutier dans le marche de l'entreprise
merci chers collègues il n'ya plus
d'inscrits avant de redonner la parole
juste je vous rappelle que nous avons
des amendements avoir après sur le texte
d outre-mer donc ne partez pas trop vite
mes chers collègues nous n'aurons pas
complètement terminée à l'issue de
l'audition des représentants ici voilà
il ya quelques amendements 2 oui il y en
a pas beaucoup mais bon il y en a
quelques-uns donc il faut être présent
pour pour pouvoir en tout cas les
adopter ou pas merci est-ce que comment
est ce que je procède à nouveau
peut-être dans le même ordre ou l'ordre
inversé peut-être monsieur allez allez
messieurs thouvenel je vais essayer de
répondre
peut-être parfaitement déjà sur la
complémentaire santé à l'heure actuelle
la pendant que je vous parle il ya un
groupe de travail tel que prévu dans
l'accord qu en est à sa troisième
réunion je crois qu est un train comme
c'est inscrit dans l'accord les parties
signataires du présent accord décidé de
constituer un groupe de travail du père
iter dont l'objet sera définir dans les
trois mois les conditions et modalités
d'une procédure transparente de mise en
concurrence tant lors de la mise en
place de la couverture remboursements
complémentaires frais de santé que lors
du réexamen périodique du ou des
organismes assureurs désigné recommandé
ce groupe de travail paritaire sera
notamment chargée de fixer des
conditions d'élaboration du cahier des
charges
les conditions de publicité de
transparence de cette mise en
concurrence les critères de sélection
des offres conforme à ce cahier des
charges et définir les critères de
l'évaluation la gestion de régimes
collectifs lors du réexamen des
conditions de mutualisation
il est également précisé est ainsi
notamment les salariés couverts par
ailleurs par un contrat collectif
obligatoire en qualité d'ayant droit
pourrait dispenser d'affiliation donc
tous ces sujets sont sur la table il ya
un groupe de travail parce que c'est les
sujets qui sont assez techniques qu'un
train de travailler il en est à sa
troisième réunion à l'heure où je parle
je pense qu'il en sortira que des choses
de bon sens sachant que vous l'avez
compris vous l'avez dit les uns les
autres
le but c'est couvrir aujourd'hui ceux
qui ne sont pas couverts et on est en
train d'y aller ça s'appelle à progrès
sur donc voilà seraient complémentaires
santé ont construit les choses quand la
transposition s'éloigne de l'accord nous
ce qu'on a vu pour nous entre le projet
de loi est d'accord c'est que c'est un
bon projet qui à quelques rares
exceptions respecte bien et le texte
qu'il faut améliorer parce que encore
une fois c'est pas une écriture
juridique de code du travail cet accord
et l'esprit alors il ya des points
notamment par exemple il serait bon
d'avoir un amendement s'il est pas
encore arrivé
qui précise que pour la complémentaire
santé le régime d'alsace moselle n'est
pas concernée puisque nos amis d'alsace
moselle sont déjà couverts le but de
l'accord c'est bien de couvrir ceux qui
ne sont pas bon ça nous paraissait
tellement évident qu'on a oublié d'en
parler mais je crois que tout le monde
est d'accord sur ce sur ce sujet cdd
pourquoi pas les supprimer
pour une raison simple c'est parce qu'un
certain nombre d'entre eux sont utiles
je veux pas supprimer le cdd pour les
vendanges sais pas je vais pas supprimer
le cdd paul remplacement d'un salarié
malade
mais il faut revenir à quelque chose de
plus équilibrée comme ça a été dit on
est partis avec des excès on essaye de
corriger ses excès sur qu'est ce qu'il y
avait sur l'accord des parties
concernées comment allons nous faire
eh bien je ne sais pas exactement
pratiquement mais la volonté
en fait la volonté des signataires la
volonté tout le monde je crois et la
volonté leur représentation nationale
c'est d'avoir quelque chose qui servent
notre pays qui servent les salariés qui
servent les entreprises on voit très
bien que l'esprit dans le projet de loi
de respecter ce qu'ont fait les
partenaires sociaux et là il n'y a pas
de raison qu'on n'y arrive pas très
concrètement mais qu'on n'avance pas en
échangeant sur le chômage
il y a
et notamment la complémentaire santé il
est prévu dans l'accord
la portabilité des droits qui améliore
notamment tout ce qui est couverture
santé il ya la portabilité et dans
l'accord d'ailleurs il ya aussi une
partie prévoyance dont on n'a pas parlé
quand on aura fait frais de santé va
falloir couvrir aussi tous les salariés
en matière de prévoyance mais ça ça va
se construire petit à petit voilà ce que
je pouvais dire grosso modo sur les
différentes questions
ah oui projet de loi globalement
stratégie dans la marche des entreprises
déjà associés les représentants des
salariés aux organes de réflexion et
direction à mon sens c'est justement du
bon sens on est toujours plus
intelligent à plusieurs avec des
expériences différentes en étant un
petit monde un petit nombre avec une
même expérience et c'est comme ça que ça
va se faire
et c'est comme ça que ça doit se faire
c'est comme ça que dire dans un certain
nombre de pays où on voit que ça marche
mieux que chez nous ça se fait c'est
alors ça va se bâtir aussi il ya des
expériences des quelques fois ça va pas
fonctionner parce que les entreprises
voudront pas joué le jeu on aura
toujours des cas qui marcheront pas mais
je pense que la majorité des cas
marcheront et moi j'ai toujours du mal à
comprendre
un chef d'entreprise qui embauchent des
collaborateurs tout en lisant cela sont
des idiots inutiles
il faut surtout pas qu'ils réfléchissent
avec moi leur avenir ces processus
inverse qu on essaye de mettre en place
merci ce pierron bien alors moi je vais
j'ai un petit désaccord sur ce que vous
avez dit madame la présidente
sur la version des normes parce qu'il me
semble que cet accord redresse un peu le
tir par rapport à ce que vous aviez à
juste raison fait mention sur une
possibilité de la version des normes qui
concrètement dans les faits n'est et peu
pratique et quand même mais mais qui
était possible et que c'était déjà une
rupture par rapport au passé
je pense que cet accord qui s'est
confirmée qui sera confirmé dans la loi
redonne une dimension de négociations de
branches plus forte qui permet d'éviter
justement la version des normes csa
renvoie beaucoup beaucoup de
négociations de branches et notamment de
branche étendu pour pouvoir infléchir ou
procéder à des souplesses dans des
procédures alors que aujourd'hui ça peut
se faire
ça peut se faire par des accords
d'entreprise uniquement voilà donc ça
c'est important de se le dire sur la
complémentaire santé j'ai envie de dire
une portabilité de 12 mois quand on perd
son emploi et c'était neuf mois
aujourd'hui donc c'est plus grands le
vrai sujet de toute façon qu'on assure
la formation qu'on a sur la
complémentaire santé qu'on a et qui
touche une égalité dans le salariat mais
l'inégalité dans les entreprises c'est
la question de la mutualisation
qu'est ce que les grandes entreprises et
petites entreprises sont prêtes à
mutualiser ensemble pour couvrir des
droits lorsque on passe d'une petite
d'une grande lorsqu'on perd son emploi
bon sur la portabilité lorsqu'on perd
son emploi de la complémentaire santé
pendant 12 mois
c'est mutualisé en terre entreprise pour
pouvoir financer une complémentaire
santé
un an avant après avoir perdu son emploi
c'est un petit pas pour certains
aujourd'hui on a dû forcer la porte
mais c'est un vrai sujet et c'est le
sujet qu'on a eues entre la divergence
de points qui a failli faire un clash
dans le patronat ce qui a des sujets
comme la complémentaire santé ou c'est
un débat entre patronat plus que entre
patronat et syndicats une fois qu'on
l'avait obtenu
c'était entre l'upa représentants des
artisans des petites entreprises avec le
medef ou là dessus il ya des vraies
divergences
les petites entreprises et l'artisanat a
besoin de mutualisation pour offrir des
droits à leurs salariés
ils peuvent pas le faire en direct et
c'est là aussi que la branche importante
alors que les grandes entreprises
eux ils veulent pas mutualiser forcément
pour les petites
donc ce sont un vrai problème dans notre
pays c'est un prime de coopération qui
imprime de compétitive le ballon mais
c'est vers ça aussi un que qu'on essaie
de tendre avec des points d'accord y
compris en mettant dans la base de
données la sous traitance un regard sur
les fournisseurs et autres c'est qu'on
soit vraiment dans une culture de
coopération plus que dans une culture de
coop compétition à court terme un du
moins disant social ce qu'on appelle
voilà donc ça y participent
la question de la mutualisation si on
peut l'enfoncer
à chaque fois qu'on négocie par petits
bouts je peux vous dire que c'est un
grand pas pour les petites les artisans
les tpe donc il faut pas le minimiser
donc douze mois ces douze mois nous
revendiquer 18 mois n'a eu douze mois
bon ben c'est le compromis
voilà on est sur 12 mois on aura un
décret sur le choix du salarié
parce qu'on a une vraie difficulté qu'on
n'a pas prévu d'un nid donc ça ça fait
partie des discussions
c'est que s'il sert à ridge à couvert ou
par son conjoint ou à la génération de
la complémentaire santé s'impose
s'impose pas comment il fait comment il
peut choisir etc et donc ça ça fait
partie des éléments qu'il faut
approfondir et il ya le groupe technique
sur les appels d'offres donc qui sera
ouvert à tout le monde
mutuelle instituts de prévoyance et
assureurs et il y aura bien sûr cette
question de choix de liberté de choix de
son organisme est pas se faire imposer
purement et simplement voilà l'objectif
que l'on vit c'est de couvrir tout le
monde c'est pas d'imposer un contrat
idyllique
quand on parle de par exemple
l'alsace-moselle là ils ont commencé à
discuter en alsace-moselle me
semble-t-il mais il y avait des
mosellans et les alsaciens voilà sur
comment en garantit un meilleur panier
puisque le panier qu'on a négocié qui
sera dans un décret il est plus haut me
semble-t-il c'est ce que nos collègues
nous dit que ce qui existe 1
sur certains points là on a un mosellans
et alsaciens et pasco voilà mais sur
certains points ça se complètent
ça va c'est en dessous en alsace-moselle
que voilà donc le tout c'est
d'harmoniser tout ça je reviens pas sur
la suppression des cdd il ya des
activités cycliques dans ce pays en a
besoin y compris pour les remplaçants
mais y compris pour des activités
cycliques
le tout c'est que ce soit pas la norme
quoi c'est ça qu'il faut éviter c'est
l'utilisation abusive qu'il faut qu'on
arrête notre pays c'est que pour le
parce que c'est risqué ou parce qu'on a
un coût du travail trop rigide et ben on
embauche en cdd ce qui est un faux
problème entre nous dans ce pays et
c'est là-dessus qu'il faut s'attaquer
mais pas la suppression des cdd cgc
lutte personnes autour de la table y
compris des c'est pas venue des non
signataires ac se soient claires entre
nous comme proposition tout l'accord ou
la coopération entre nous comment on va
faire moi je pense qu'on doit pouvoir
être en capacité de montrer que vous
comme nous dans ce pays on a un rôle à
jouer qu'on ait un rôle à jouer avec une
légitimité nous des salariés avec une
élection vous du peuple avec vos
élections et que ça ça peut se cohabiter
ces sacs en vain c'est ça que je parle
quand je parle de connaître sans
autocensure ni des uns ni des autres et
en ayant bien sûr le respect de ceux qui
sont engagés pour pas donner la prime à
ceux qui serait pas engagé voilà c'est
ça la difficulté de l'exercice
mais c'est un exercice me semble-t-il
intéressant porteurs pour l'avenir
voilà et on doit essayer au moins de le
réussir
c'est ça ce qui est devant nous un sur
la table non moi je pose pas au
contraire c'est pour ça que je parle de
co-construction de coopération mais en
ayant bien en tête que chacun a sa
légitimité
chacun a représentent bon voila il assez
pendant qu'ils représentent et je ne
pose pas les autres les uns les autres
mais si pour une fois on arrivait à
collaborer à coopérer plus tôt pour
créer la norme sociale ensemble en
préciser les contours et la porte et ça
serait bien voilà c'est le l'exercice
qu'on a à faire
alors après comment on travaille
ensemble nous comme on a travaillé
ensemble on a eu par exemple on a tous
les amendements puisqu'ils ont public
les amendements et donc et puis on a un
lien avec le gouvernement en un lien que
le rapporteur comme on lisait et donc il
ya plein d'eau dition qui se font par
les groupes qu'il permet de se
construire ou de se forger une visite et
une idée pour ceux qui le souhaitent sur
l'état d'esprit un peu ce qu'on fait là
mais séparés de chaque groupe
parlementaire qui amènent des
amendements peu ou prou les amendements
ils sont trois catégories ce qu'on a vu
à l'assemblée nationale il ya les
amendements politique
voilà qui n'ont rien à voir avec l'ani
remise en cause des 35 heures en fait
c'était essaiera je passe il ya les
amendements qu'ils sont qui ne répondent
pas à qui sont pas politiques forcément
mais qui ne répondent pas à l'esprit de
la nuit j'ai pas des gens n'avaient ce
matin mais on est plus d'exemples en
tête mais bon il y en a un
voilà qui vont beaucoup plus loin sur la
formation par exemple sur la formation
s'est volontairement
on avait tous envie d'aller plus loin
mais une concertation en cours et y ait
négocié un projet de loi en cours dont
on a fait le choix d'en rester là pour
l'âme et administrateur salarié on
voulait aller plus loin mais on s'est
dit vaut mieux que ça les parlementaires
là qu'il fasse voilà donc il ya des
éléments comme ça et puis nous faire
monter nos avis sur les amendements on
donne un peu voilà par exemple sur pas
vous cacher que sur la mobilité interne
qui est source de c'est compliqué il ya
des sujets un canton le rédige
juridiquement on voit là on a fait un
tour de piste avec le rapporteur le
gouvernement je sais pas ce que ça va
donner mais vernon prom propose là une
nouvelle rédaction de l'article 10 sur
cette partie de la mobilité ou celle qui
avait été on est passé de motifs
personnels motif économique c'est pas là
dessus mais c'est sur l'accompagnement
et autres d'après ce que j'ai compris
moi j'ai vu le projet de réécriture je
trouve qu'ils précisent bien la pensée
des négociateurs voilà c'est comme ça
qu'on travaille ensemble
c'est par mes parents comptent physique
par coup de téléphone et de toute façon
nous on fait remonter l'eau rapporteur
et au ministère notre avis sur les
amendements déposés
voilà on essaie de ont fait un tableau 1
et on met notre avis après l'ancien
continent tient pas compte mais au moins
il connaît notre position
voilà ce que j'avais envie de dire voilà
pour les travaux de la commission des
affaires sociales du sénat si vous
souhaitez revoir ses auditions elles
sont disponibles en vod sur notre site
internet publicsenat.fr bonne fin de
journée à tous